bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat sur France 24 Vladimir Poutine a
promis des répliques sévères en cas de
nouvelles attaques ukrainiennes contre
la Russie le président russe a lancé une
campagne massive de bombardements dans
plusieurs régions ukrainiennes l'armée
russe a utilisé des armes de longue
portée contre l'infrastructure
énergétique militaire et de
communication de l'Ukraine a lancé
Vladimir Poutine lors de son Conseil de
sécurité qui rassemblait ses principaux
ministres deux jours après l'explosion
qui a endommagé le pont de Crimée pour
la première fois depuis le 26 juin Kiev
a été touché d'autres villes vous le
voyez sur cette carte d'autres villes
ukrainiennes ont été frappées notamment
Jitomir ni pro zaporigia ou encore vive
il y a eu au moins une dizaine de morts
Washington assure maintenant bien sûr
l'Ukraine de son soutien Emmanuel Macron
déplore un changement profond de la
nature de la guerre alors jusqu'où la
riposte de Vladimir Poutine jusqu'où ira
le président russe et bien on en parle
avec mes invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés Elena volechine bonsoir Elena
grand reporter un France 24 ancienne
correspondante en Russie bienvenue à
vous Oksana Panova microfanova bonsoir
enseignante chercheuse à linal à Alco
cherche senior à l'Institut d'histoire
mondiale de l'Académie nationale des
sciences du crâne à Kiev et vous êtes
réfugiés d'ailleurs en France depuis
mars 2022 merci d'être avec nous ce soir
collègue cops bonsoir historien
géographe professeur de géopolitique à
l'American in the Voice city of us on a
par Skype à Bruxelles Jean Vincent
Brisset bonsoir à vous général de
brigade aérienne et chercheurs associés
à l'Iris bienvenue
vous pouvez réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux sur le hashtag débat F24
Vladimir Poutine je vous le disais a
accusé à Kiev d'avoir commis un acte
terroriste je cite qui a détruit en
partie le pont de Crimée reliant la
Russie à la Crimée le président russe a
justifié sa riposte lors de son Conseil
de sécurité qui a fait aussi encore sous
le choc des bombardements mais aussi
zapporigia vivent beaucoup plus à
l'ouest on va faire d'abord un point en
image avec Nabi à Makhloufi
une course contre la montre est engagée
les secours le savent il faut agir vite
contenir les flammes et évacuer les
blessés en urgence
des carrefours routiers des parcs
publics et des sites touristiques ont
été bombardés dans la capitale ce sont
les premières frappes depuis plus de 3
mois des frappes précisées ciblées selon
le président
ellenski
des dizaines de missiles iraniens de
type shahides sont tirés ils veulent
créer la panique et le chaos ils veulent
détruire le système énergétique ils sont
désespérés ils vivent soumis gitomir
vinitza ou encore ni pro plus au sud ici
la falt a été soulevée l'un des missiles
a terminé sa course au pied de ses
immeubles résidentiels
et vous savez pourquoi les rues sont
bombardés
non je ne sais pas il n'y a pas de cible
ici maudit soit Poutine
de se mettre à l'abri sous terre dans
une station de métro on s'y attendait
après avoir bombardé le pont de Crimée
des représailles pleinement assumées par
Vladimir Poutine
si les tentatives d'attentat terroristes
sur notre territoire se poursuivent les
réponses de la Russie seront sévères et
seront de la même ampleur que celle des
menaces posées à la Fédération de Russie
personne ne doit en avoir le moindre
doute
l'ancien président russe s'appelle lui
au démantèlement total du pouvoir
ukrainien
crack notre correspondant à Kiev bonsoir
Gulliver la capitale est encore sous le
choc quel est l'état d'esprit de la
population
je dirais que l'émotion que je ressens
exprimé le plus souvent par les
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui c'est la colère
en réalité certes il y a le choc il y a
la peur les gens pour la première fois
depuis de très longs mois ont dû se
réfugiés dans le métro ou dans les
sous-sols de leurs immeubles les autres
abris qu'il y a dans la capitale et pour
beaucoup d'entre eux en réalité c'était
la première fois puisque ils étaient
partis très rapidement de Kiev au
premier jour de l'invasion mais ce soir
on ne voit pas de mouvement comparable
d'exaude de la capitale
ukrainienne il y a relativement peu
d'embouteillages à la sortie de la ville
d'après les logiciels de navigation
alors il y a je pense
effectivement un esprit beaucoup plus de
défiance de d'un sentiment que il faut
absolument que l'Ukraine résiste et chez
certains même une certaine optimisme des
analystes militaires Ukrainiens disent
que la Russie ne pourra pas continuer
comme ça pendant plusieurs jours parce
que ces des millions de dollars ils
n'auront pas la capacité à le faire et
aussi selon leur porte-parole c'est
difficile à vérifier mais les systèmes
de défense ont été aériens Ukrainiens
auraient assez bien travaillé
aujourd'hui ils disent que sur 83
requêtes- sur l'Ukraine pendant la
première période de l'attaque ce matin
41 ont été abattus par les missiles
solaires merci beaucoup gilet
Oxana microfanova vous qui êtes réfugiés
depuis peu en France vous avez j'imagine
aussi des contacts sur place est-ce que
vous pouvez rebondir sur peut-être ce
qu'a dit Gulliver on parle de 83
missiles donc ils ont été qui aurait
frappé l'Ukraine et puis la moitié
aurait été intercepté par les Ukrainiens
ce sont aussi vos informations qui est
état d'esprit de vos contacts
il faut ajouter aussi un détail il ne
s'agit pas que des missiles mais aussi
il y a de drones donc ce Congo qui est
là aussi a acheté des drones iraniennes
et bien sûr on dit au début on ne sait
pas comment ça marche donc on a eu la
période d'étudier parce que les forces
aérien de l'armée Ariane ukrainienne a
dit on va étudier des drones et après on
va chercher des méthodes à battre les
drones donc du coup j'ai l'information
qui est à peu près 13 drones étaient
abattues et parmi ces drones c'était ce
drone iranienne qui s'appelle Chakib et
c'est vrai que shakid pose certains
problèmes exactement quel type de
problème si ce drone vole très bas et
surtout dans le nu dans le noir c'est
très difficile détecter ce don donc
l'armée
ukrainien doit chercher les méthodes
commandes il faut abattre le drone on a
trouvé certains méthodes mais au début
il faut apprendre le situation ensuite
c'est qu'il s'agit exactement de ces
femmes de tout l'été malheureusement
c'était prévisible parce que vous m'avez
déjà invité sur ce plateau et vous
pouvez vous rappeler quand on a parlé de
contrefensif dans l'est de l'Ukraine qui
est le Tailor réaction c'est le bord de
ma de l'infrastructure des entreprises
de l'énergie donc vous pensez que ça
allait arriver ce bombardement un peu
systématique de plusieurs vies
ukrainiennes mais bien sûr bien sûr on
ne peut pas calculer le jour on ne peut
pas calculer l'heure de symptômes
pardonnements mais cette tactique russe
c'est plus simple à réaliser parce que
maintenant tout le monde parle de l'arme
nucléaire je comprends que j'ai assez
important
c'est très simple à réaliser il faut
juste bombarder des avions qui se
trouvent en Russie et qui se trouve
belle aussi et les dons Elena quel est
l'objectif de Vladimir Poutine est-ce
que c'est terrorisé la population il a
évoqué donc un je le recite des armes de
haute précision avec des sites qui sont
des infrastructures énergétiques
militaires et de communication est-ce
que est-ce que ce sont effectivement les
cibles dont on parle là c'est clairement
de terroriser oui
je rejoins ce que disait Oksana à
l'instant c'est à dire que jusqu'à
présent dans cette guerre Vladimir
Poutine frappe et l'armée russe frappait
l'infrastructure civile mais il n'y a
jamais eu il n'y a jamais eu de mise en
relation de la cause à la conséquence
c'est-à-dire que s'il y avait des dégâts
ou des destructions ou des bombardements
sur les villes du crayon la Russie a
toujours dit c'est un fake ce n'est pas
vrai la gare de cramator ce qui a fait
une cinquantaine de morts ce n'est pas
nous ce sont les Ukrainiens qui se sont
bombardés eux-mêmes la même chose avec
le centre commercial à cremensuk etc
donc ils n'ont jamais assumé ils ont
toujours dit on ne c'est une
démilitarisation de l'Ukraine on ne
frappe que des cibles militaires à
partir du moment où vous le dit
marselinsky a lancé la contre-offensive
le premier septembre cette petite
musique elle commençait déjà à monter
les Russes la propagande russe disait on
va on ne va plus ménager les civils on
va arrêter d'y aller avec le dos de la
cuillère il faut maintenant on a plus le
choix on est acculé les Ukrainiens
avancent et donc il faut vraiment qu'on
leur fasse comprendre
à l'assumer petit à petit on se souvient
que le 15 septembre il y a eu des
frappes qui ont complètement débranché
de enlever
hors tension la ville de kerkiff vous
vous souvenez que nous étions en duplex
avec vous Stéphanie gtaquer et on a dû
interrompre notre duplex parce que il y
avait eu des bombardements sur carquif
dans le district voisin toutes les
l'électricité de là où je me trouvais
toutes les cristaux effectivement a été
débranchée là ce qui change c'est
l'ampleur de cette de cette attaque et
c'est le fait que Vladimir Poutine en
personne maintenant assume dit voilà
c'est nous qui avons bombardé et nous
continuerons de le faire évidemment avec
sa rhétorique habituelle comme quoi
c'est une réponse à l'agression à
l'attentat terroriste sur le pont de
criminel est-ce qu'il y a un lien tout
de même avec ce qui s'est passé avec ce
cette explosion du pont justement qui
relie la Crimée à la Russie est-ce que
l'effondrement de s'était dit fils cher
à Vladimir Poutine puisqu'il avait
inauguré me semble-t-il juste après
avoir annexé la Crimée est-ce que ça
aussi ça participe de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui où est-ce
qu'effectivement c'était peut-être
planifié depuis un certain moment depuis
un certain temps c'est bombardements il
est certain qu'à court terme c'est ce
qui a déclenché cette attaque là il est
clair que cette attaque était déjà
planifié au cas où effectivement Poutine
ne pourrait pas reprendre les les
territoires perdus là depuis quelques
jours quelques semaines il est certain
que l'explosion du pont de kirsch qui
est à la fois très stratégique et
symbolique à mille peu au fou a mis le
feu aux poudres au Kremlin il y a autre
chose moi j'y vois autre chose c'est une
manière de dire
la prochaine fois nous ou quand nous
voudrons nous pourrons mettre des têtes
nucléaires sur ces missiles je pensais
c'est un signal alors osera-t-il le
faire
certains que c'est un pas de plus dans
l'escalade oui maintenant est-ce que
est-ce qu'il bombardera avec des armes
nucléaires tactiques ou non ça c'est un
c'est un autre débat peut-être que vous
voulez rebondir 83 missiles en fait on
entendait tout de même Gulliver qui
disait que la moitié avait été quand
même intercepté par les Ukrainiens
est-ce que Vladimir Poutine peut d'abord
continuer à pilonner de cette manière
est-ce qu'il en a les moyens militaires
à votre avis et finalement quel est
l'objectif
alors ce qu'on n'arrive pas à savoir à
l'heure actuelle c'est quels sont les
capacités du côté russe de sortir du
matériel des usines parce que il est
certain que les stocks de départ sont
très largement consommés et qu'à l'heure
actuelle ce qui peut arriver sur le sur
le marché enfin sur le marché sur le sur
le combat ce sont soit des missiles qui
étaient stockés dans un état plus ou
moins bon parce qu'en Russie on stocke
tout ils étaient donc plus ou moins bon
état et qui ont été remis en état de
fonctionnement plus ou moins bien et
puis des choses qui sortent neuves
d'usine vraisemblablement des versions
simplifiées parce que il y a des
pénuries de composants électroniques en
Russie donc il y a des possibilités mais
on n'arrive pas à avoir les flots il est
seuls informations qu'on a sur les
informations qui sont données soit par
des directement par les services
Ukrainiens soit par des services
extrêmement proches des Ukrainiens ou
des journalistes cornacés par les les
services Ukrainiens donc un petit peu
difficile de savoir ce qui se passe moi
ce que je note c'est que la les frappes
ont lieu sur des centrales et enfin des
des sous-stations électriques les
stations 750 kilovolt et 330 kilos volts
qui sont les nœuds de répartition de
l'énergie électrique à l'intérieur de
l'Ukraine ça c'est nouveau comme type de
frappe et c'est nous et ça correspond à
une montée une escalade des deux côtés
il y a eu ce pont Crimée il semble qui
est quand même de plus en plus souvent
des frappes ukrainiennes à l'intérieur
du territoire russe de d'origine pas
seulement dans les dans les territoires
annexés et même dans le territoire russe
d'origine et ça c'est considéré comme
quelque chose d'inacceptable donc ça
justifie une montée en puissance et une
montée des tirs avec en plus changement
de commandement à la tête de l'opération
dite spéciale on peut parler de ce
changement de commandement dont on fait
au café référence générale c'est Sergueï
suroviking c'est un gars ils sont Viking
donc il vient de prendre qui vient
d'être nommé de l'opération militaire
spéciale dirigeait le regroupement des
forces Sud en Ukraine d'après ce que
j'ai lu on l'appelait le boucher d'Alep
puisque en fait c'était lui qui était en
Syrie est-ce que ça participe est-ce que
effectivement c'est vraiment un boucher
comme boucher d'Alep comme on l'appelait
est-ce que finalement ce bombardement ça
n'est pas une coïncidence ça serait
vraiment son ce type de stratégie
son type de stratégie on parle de bouche
rappeler quand même le printemps et pas
exactement ce général mais qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé à bout de chia qu'est-ce que
c'est passé au bout de chia qu'est-ce
qu'il y en a découvertes est-ce que ce
n'est pas le comportement de boucher au
pluriel on peut dire donc si on a mal en
général et dire que le boucher mais il y
a plein d'autres aussi lui il peut bien
sûr devenir plus sévère utiliser une
tactique plus sévère c'est que
conséquence de résultats qui on n'arrive
pas à faire grand-chose avec l'armée
ukrainienne du coup il faut se retrouver
vers les plus faibles c'est-à-dire
terroriser les civils ukrainiennes parce
que c'est le cible sur plus simple à
atteint terroriser les civils et les
faire le niveau de vie des Ukrainiens
dans ce portable et c'est je pense qu'il
est aussi va continuer ce tactique en
sachant aussi ce qui est le vert arrive
mais aussi peut-être ces méthodes
d'examiner aussi le soutien de
européenne parce que l'Ukraine vraiment
vraiment dépendante soutien des
Européens et quand le verre arrive avec
des problèmes énergétiques on ne sait
pas vraiment comment va réagir l'Europe
et ce qui nous allions européens sont
vraiment Unis on va revenir justement
sur ce soutien des Européens d'abord
cette réaction d'Alexandre lucaschenko
qui a accusé la Pologne la Lituanie et
l'Ukraine de préparer des attaques
terroristes je cite et un soulèvement en
Biélorussie le président biélorus a
annoncé donc le déploiement d'un
groupement militaire régional avec
Moscou on va l'écouter
en raison de l'escalade aux frontières
occidentales de notre état nous avons
convenu de déployer un groupement
militaire régional commun de la
Fédération de Russie et de la République
de Biélorussie oublie
la réaction du chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne couliba au micro de Marc
peyrolman
c'est très inquiétant non seulement pour
l'Ukraine mais aussi pour les pays de
l'Union européenne la Lettonie la
Lituanie et la Pologne qui ont une
frontière avec la bière Russie
on ne sait pas ce que peut faire cette
force conjointe d'intervention sur ces
territoires comment ils vont se
comporter donc c'est vraiment une
dégradation très grave de la sécurité
non seulement pour l'Ukraine mais
également pour l'Union européenne
d'aggravation très grave une dégradation
très grave du conflit c'est ce que dit
couliba donc le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne on a vu quand même la
détermination d'Alexandre lucaschenko
qui est un peu une sorte de le dernier
allié véritable de Vladimir Poutine mais
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il peut
ouvrir un front au nord par exemple
écoutez c'est très torique de de du pays
menacé donc de la nécessité d'intervenir
nous l'avons décortiqué avec vous dans
vue de Russie ce mythe de l'agression
préventive pardonnez-moi le parallèle
mais on va le refaire parce que ici
c'est important c'est le même qu'avait
utilisé Hitler avant l'invasion de la
Pologne c'est-à-dire l'absence
d'alternative pour le pays c'est qui
n'est que d'envahir c'est exactement la
même chose que fait Vladimir Poutine
lorsqu'il lance l'opération militaire en
Ukraine puisqu'il dit si nous n'y allons
pas et bien nous n'avons pas nous
n'aurons pas d'autre choix nous allons
être la Russie va être détruite c'est
exactement ce que dit aujourd'hui
Alexandre Loukachenko c'est-à-dire le
pays est menacé nous risqueront une
attaque donc cela laisse très fortement
supposer qu'effectivement il va y aller
on va rappeler ce qui s'est passé au
début de la guerre c'est-à-dire que
l'Ukraine a été envahi en trois endroits
depuis le sud la région de Rostov et les
républiques autoproclamés de donuts de
Laurence que Bern Mario Paul depuis le
nord depuis la région de Belgorod vers
carquish et depuis encore plus au nord à
l'ouest la Biélorussie vers Kiev donc
depuis le début de la guerre la
Biélorussie sert de base arrière à
l'invasion russe les armées entre aussi
par par cet endroit seulement depuis le
début Alexandre lucaschenko avait une
position extrêmement réservée on se
demandait est-ce qu'il allait entrer ou
non en réel cobelligérance c'est vrai ou
la peur entendu c'est dans la pluie du
tout entendu donc là cette déclaration
cela laisse entendre qu'il y aurait-tu
peut-être un accord ou un impact ou
une table supplémentaire entre entre lui
et Vladimir Poutine parce que on avait
il rejoignait tant la rhétorique de
Vladimir Poutine avant et au tout début
de l'invasion qu'on se disait mais c'est
comme si la Russie finalement avait déjà
annexé la Biélorussie et Alexandre
lucaschenko n'était là que pour être le
porte-parole de Vladimir Poutine et on
l'a plus du tout entendu après et vous
avez raison de souligner je termine
là-dessus que Vladimir Poutine au jour
d'aujourd'hui et lâché par tous ces
alliés par exemple il y avait des
exercices militaires conjoint qui
devaient se tenir au Kirghistan ils ont
le Kirghistan les a annulés les casaques
aussi se sont mis vraiment en retrait et
donc on voit que Vladimir Poutine il est
il est lâché par tous ses alliés en Asie
centrale dans le Caucase et là cette
réaction d'Alexandre lucaschenko elle
est à la fois intéressante à analyser à
la pas très inquiétante Olek comme ça
inquiétant justement est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'un pourrait s'ouvrir au nord
donc beaucoup plus près de Kiev avec
l'aide du biélorus il a déjà existé ce
front
depuis un certain nombre de mois on a
aussi entendu d'ailleurs que la
population biélorus ne serait peut-être
pas voilà forcément favorable à une
localisation parce que
là la question parce que il n'y a pas
besoin de l'Ukraine et de la Lituanie
pour provoquer un soulèvement du peuple
biélorusse parce que ce soulèvement a
déjà eu lieu et ils ont massivement il y
a très peu d'années ils ont manif
massivement manifestés ils ont élu une
présidente opposée à lukashan que et en
plus nous Cachen qui avait joué un
meublé avait joué un très mauvais jeu
parce qu'il avait pas été fidèle à
Poutine il a essayé d'être
de jouer les indépendants il a été
complètement débordé justement par euh
par une opposition qui était d'ailleurs
pas tout à fait une
ou qui peut-être devenu
d'ailleurs par Poutine lui-même mais qui
est devenu finalement
vu le vox populi une vraie une véritable
opposition donc il a il a très peur
parce que d'un côté il a il a finalement
tout un peuple qui est contre lui il a
Poutine et mais cela dit il doit
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
chef de l'État encore sinon il aurait
été balayé par par ce mouvement
populaire pour tout Inuit a clairement
dit maintenant tu te tiens tranquille tu
arrêtes tes bêtises sinon si sinon je
lâche je lâche la foule contre toi qui
t'a quitte à la re manipuler plus tard à
trouver un autre un autre pantin à ta
place donc ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui
est ce n'est pas il n'est pas
confortable dans sa position il est mais
évidemment il est obligé de de jouer
avec Poutine qui de tout clairement lui
a demandé de le soutenir militairement
mais je répète on l'a déjà vu au début
au début de la guerre il y a eu tout un
front nord biélorus qui a avancé vers
vers le sud général Brisset vous pensez
qu'effectivement il pourrait y avoir
maintenant à nouveau un front nord avec
l'aide de Alexandre Lucas and Co
justement
d'après ce que j'ai compris à l'époque
il y a jamais eu de troupes biélorus qui
ont participé à ce fonds Nord est-ce
qu'on or c'était une tentative une
erreur colossale des Russes sur le plan
du renseignement qui ont pensé qu'on
avançant très vite vers Kiev ils
arriveraient à faire tomber le régime la
Biélorussie a servi de base arrière bien
sûr mais je pense pas qu'elle était
directement impliquée à l'heure actuelle
de la même manière que les
Occidentaux ont espéré qu'il allait se
passer des choses en Moldavie entre
aussi stries ils espèrent qu'on va
refaire un Maiden bis à réussir à
provoquer un my dan bis
en Biélorussie je ne pense pas que ça
soit extrêmement réaliste ça fait partie
du rouge full thinking d'un certain
nombre de gens mais je pense pas que ça
soit extrêmement réaliste à l'heure
actuelle mais aussi
[Musique]
provoquée de l'extérieur et qui serait
effectivement extrêmement
dommageable pour les Russes vous les
réagir les comme ça au contraire le
risque pour nous cacher un soulèvement
général de la population qu'on a déjà vu
je répète on l'a vu il y a combien
c'était il y a 2 3 ans aujourd'hui on
peut faire tomber le régime aussi
justement et alors justement faire
intervenir vous avez dû déjà ce qui se
passe en Russie les les centaines de
milliers de réfugiés qui quittent le
pays
les régiments qui sont au bord de la
mutinerie regardez ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux sociaux russes imaginez ce
qui va se passer en Biélorussie où il y
a eu déjà un soulèvement de la
population il y a très peu de temps ça
peut si location que alors effectivement
il y a jamais eu de troupes de citoyens
biélorusses sur le front mais s'il les
envoie là il peut y avoir soulèvement
je pense par exemple pourquoi pas de
mettre le soldats biéloruss dans russe
de simplement ce sera un peu double jeu
et on va sur le front parce que par
exemple je loue des témoignages de
certains gens de région de Kiev que
quelquefois on a entendu accent plutôt
bleu russe soit disant le soldat russe
donc je sais pas est-ce que le cacher un
cas suffisamment de cette créativité
mais peut-être c'est pas exclu d'envoyer
quelques unités avec changement aussi
d'uniformes comme ça ce sera plus malin
on peut dire ça n'a pas l'air si simple
en tout cas Elena moi sur la capacité de
soulèvement je suis réservée aussi en
sachant que effectivement ce sont des
régimes qui régime qui ont extrêmement
verrouillé leur opposition et qui ont
mis en place quand je dis des régimes
c'est en Russie aussi on a vu des
manifestations au cours de ces dernières
années qui allonnent de la guerre enfin
toute capacité de rébellion a été annulé
par des lois répressives extrêmement
dures c'est ce qui s'est passé en
Biélorussie après le je dirais pas qu'il
y a jamais eu de biélor de biélorusses
qui ont combattu depuis le 24 février en
Ukraine il y a aux côtés des Russes un
certain nombre de formations qui sont
pas forcément d'ailleurs déguisés dans
des uniformes russes juste des
mercenaires des bataillons on parle
beaucoup de Wagner mais il y a aussi
beaucoup d'autres formations de
mercenaires dont on n'a jamais entendu
parler et qui sont là donc il y a tout à
fait
je pense que en fait s'il y a des
Biélorusses en tout cas c'est un
phénomène qui reste marginal et il n'y a
pas eu d'entrée formelle effectivement
de kobelligérances de la part de la part
de la Bible ça serait quelque chose de
nouveau oui réaction occidentale elles
se sont bien sûr multipliées Washington
qui a donc assure à nouveau à l'Ukraine
son soutien Emmanuel Macron qui a
déploré un changement profond de nature
de la guerre a dit le président français
et Berlin qui a annoncé une réunion
d'urgence virtuelle demain à mardi des
dirigeants du G7 avec volodymir Zelinski
on fait un point en images avec Noémie
roche
ils essaient de nous détruire tous de
nous effacer de la surface de la Terre
les mots du président ukrainien après
les bombardements russes les plus
intenses depuis des mois en Ukraine en
déplacement en Mayenne le président
français a exprimé son inquiétude on va
voir
au téléphone très longuement je tiendrai
une réunion dès mon retour de Mayenne
j'aurai l'occasion de m'exprimer dans un
cadre approprié évidemment la France a
eu le j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire ce
matin et condamné avec la plus grande
fermeté les frappes délibérées de la
Russie sur l'ensemble du territoire
ukrainien et contre des civils ce qui
est un changement profond de la nature
de ça Emmanuel Macron promet d’accroître
l'aide militaire de la France à
l'Ukraine tout comme Berlin qui a
réitéré la solidarité de l'Allemagne et
les autres États du G7 à Kiev
l'Allemagne fera tout pour mobiliser une
aide supplémentaire et en particulier
pour aider à réparer et restaurer les
infrastructures civiles endommagées et
détruites telles que l'approvisionnement
en capacité et en chaleur
message de soutien également de la part
de Londres qui dénonce des bombardements
inacceptables des frappes barbares pour
l'Union européenne
la Russie opte pour une tactique
consistant à viser et à bombarder les
civils
c'est quelque chose qui va l'encontre du
droit international humanitaire et ce
ciblage de civils équivaut un crime de
guerre
l'OTAN condamné aussi des attaques
horribles et aveugles et assurer de son
soutien aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra
une réunion virtuelle du G7 aura lieu
mardi avec volody merzelenski sur la
situation en Ukraine
on va écouter à présent la première
ministre d'Estonie
nous sommes ici à la frontière est de
l'Union européenne derrière nous se
tient la Russie
nous envoyons un message clair aux
Ukrainiens nous vous soutenons partout
les moyens possibles
ce qu'il faut assurément faire c'est
d'envoyer une défense aérienne depuis
les pays alliés adjacents pour que les
Ukrainiens puissent défendre leur ville
et leur civils parce que la Russie est
déterminée à augmenter ses attaques
contre les citoyens
ce que demande la première ministre
d'Estonie pour l'instant bien sûr ce
n'est pas aidé obtenu parce que ça
voudrait dire à kobelligérant c'est ça
un petit peu tout le débat mais elle
demande effectivement qu'ils défense
anti-aérienne de la part de pays donc
qui sont voisins donc ils font partie de
l'OTAN donc tout simplement de début de
la guerre on a déjà demandé à l'aide
avec le système de défense
la question de se poser soit fermer le
ciel par le loi ce qui a dit non on ne
va pas fermer le ciel par le loi dans ce
cas ils font Matt beaucoup de ce système
le crâne en Allemagne qui assuré donc
d'ailleurs aussi envoyé donc livrer un
premier système de défense anti-aérienne
aux Ukrainiens donc tout à fait ça ça le
processus déjà ça a mis en route mais
par exemple je peux peut-être citerne
notre sécurité de conseils de sécurité
il a dit le problème c'est la vitesse
avec qui on va recevoir ce système est
aussi c'est la quantité la quantité de
ce système parce que il faut regarder le
quart de l'Ukraine son prix très grand
si on peut comme la France il couvrir
ces pays et beaucoup de villes c'est
très compliqué ça signifie que vraiment
il faut voir beaucoup de ce système
elles vont encore plus loin en fait le
premier ministre d'Estonie enfin on ira
encore plus loin au moment où on va les
livrer ces systèmes finalement à
l'Ukraine et puisque l'Allemagne les a
déjà promis cet été et maintenant
berbock promet que cette promesse sera
enfin sera tenue des Affaires étrangères
allemandes de personnes en ukra qui
s'étonne qui s'étonne du fait que ça n'a
pas encore été fait puisqu'en Ukraine
c'est une guerre qui vient du ciel
lorsque vous marchez en Ukraine et que
vous entendez dans toutes les villes
constamment une alerte anti-aérienne
vous marchez comme ça vous courbez les
épaules parce que c'est ce sont des
bombes qui peuvent du ciel en permanence
et qui vont et d'ailleurs les Ukrainiens
ont intercepté je ne sais plus la moitié
la moitié des missiles voilà les Russes
et missiles s'ils avaient eu des
systèmes de défense antiarienne sans
doute ils en ont intercepté davantage
donc il y a un moment donné dans cette
guerre où cela paraît quand même comme
une évidence que l'Ukraine a réellement
besoin de se défendre anti-aériennes au
Lecques comme ça mais là on est quand on
écoute la première ministre estonienne
on se dit que ça à la limite
c'est-à-dire que ça voudrait dire que
ces pays deviennent kobelligérant dans
ce cas
faut savoir qu'il y a déjà des troupes
de l'OTAN qui ne sont pas estoniennes
sur le territoire de l'Estonie depuis
les depuis avant le début de la guerre
j'étais en Estonie justement la veille
en fait j'étais j'y étais le 20 ou le 21
février on savait qu'il y avait déjà des
des troupes des de l'OTAN qui était
prête intervenir au cas où on ne savait
pas encore exactement même s'il y a les
y avoir une attaque on s'en doutait mais
bon ça n'est pas encore comment cette
guerre allait se passer mais il faut
aussi se mettre à la place des Estoniens
le risque est énorme si escalade
signe une grande internationalisation du
conflit il faut absolument que les
stonies soient prêtes parce que c'est un
tout petit pays qui sera mais balayé en
en quelques heures si s'il n'y a pas des
des systèmes de défense assez
solide pour tenir sur place
on passera encore à une autre étape dans
l'escalade
quand on entend la première
ministrement stupéfiant d'imaginer que
la Russie puisse attaquer l'Estonie ou
la les états balles ou essayer de
rentrer en Pologne on est cette
opération elle est en Ukraine et je
pense que c'est à la limite des forces
de la Russie vouloir aller ailleurs
serait absolument suicidé déjà ça va pas
si bien que ça pour les Russes en
Ukraine ils ont pas du tout les moyens
d'aller plus loin et plus fort sauf que
moi je disais exactement la même chose
que le général à propos de l'Ukraine
maintenant je regrette mes paroles j'ai
dit non c'est ce serait complètement
stupide et suicidaire d'attaquer
l'Ukraine voyez ce qui se passe
alors oui donc en fait pour vous c'est
une option possible sur justement les
forces russes Oxana cette mobilisation
des rues son évoquait 200 000 russes
mobilisées est-ce que on en est loin
est-ce que effectivement on a
l'impression qu'il va y avoir une
riposte
c'est difficile vraiment prévoir parce
que il faut il faut vraiment avoir
comment la situation ça va de la paix
mais on peut dire que déjà les gens qui
sont mobilisés je pense qu'ils ne sont
pas vraiment psychologiquement et
techniquement faire la guerre donc je
pense que c'est ce Russe ne sont pas de
bonnes soldats beaucoup d'eux elles sont
de mobilier qui sont mobilisés
maintenant ils n'ont pas beaucoup ni
motivation parce que c'est qu'ils font
mais aussi ni préparation mais quand
même c'est aussi c'est la tactique russe
utilisait la chair canon donc la chair
akonone utilisait beaucoup beaucoup de
soldats donc du coup bien sûr il faut
prendre quand même il faut prendre soin
de joke ce sera quand même facteur c'est
agréable pour mener pour pour mener
cette guerre pour les Ukrainiens Elena
on en est où de cette mobilisation
d'après justement vos informations parce
que 200000 russes c'était ce qui était
annoncé la semaine dernière par Moscou
mais je pense qu'on peut on ne peut pas
prendre davantage sérieux ce chiffre de
200 000 qu'on ne peut prendre au sérieux
le fait que la Russie ne frappe que des
cibles militaires en Ukraine lorsqu'elle
le dit c'est à dire que ce sont des
chiffres qui sont annoncés pour annoncer
des chiffres l'objectif de 300 000 c'est
un objectif qui est annoncé pour
annoncer un chiffre l'objet l'objectif
atteint de 200000 1 2 semaines c'est
parce qu'on veut donner un chiffre en
réalité lorsque vous voyez ce qui se
passe dans les je sais pas comment
traduire cela en français du russe mais
dans les commissariats militaires disons
les voyelles camates ou ou qui recrutent
sur le terrain et il essaye de
surremplir les quotas en fait ils
prennent tout ce qu'ils peuvent Vladimir
Poutine il faut pas oublier que il fait
ce qu'il peut avec les moyens qu'il a
donc lorsqu'on pose la question de ces
fins de ces objectifs de qu'est-ce qu'il
va faire après il faut simplement
questionner quels moyens il a et on n'en
sait rien en réalité ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il Mobilis on peut
pas parler on a vu la fuite des Russes
ou même de Russes en tout cas on peut
parler de débandade simplement il a dit
que il faut il voulait mobiliser des
réservistes des gens qui savent faire la
guerre des gens entraînés il veut
toujours garder l'apparence une
opération qui est sous contrôle en
réalité il rafle tout ce qu'ils peuvent
c'est-à-dire y compris des gens qui ne
commission médicale qui ne sont pas
entraînés avant d'aller au front qui ne
sont même pas équipés qui doivent venir
avec leur propre matériel etc il y a
effectivement des dizaines de milliers
de Russes qui fuient le pays à l'heure
actuelle c'est comme ça qu'elle se passe
cette mobilisation il faut aussi voir
que cette mobilisation et on l'a dit est
redit c'est la guerre qui s'invite dans
les foyers russes alors que jusqu'à
présent la Russie soutenait massivement
en tout cas en apparence dans l'opinion
publique je vais terminer l'opération
spéciale la guerre enfin voilà comme il
l'appelle l'opération spéciale ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans les régions à
l'aune de cette mobilisation et c'est
frappes de longues portées sur les
villes ukrainiennes cela répond à
l'attente de l'opinion publique russe
pourquoi parce que les Russes avec la
mobilisation ils n'ont pas cessé de
soutenir l'opération spéciale parce que
la propagande a tant travaillé les
esprits que les Russes jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ils sont persuadés dans dans
la dans la masse en tout cas visible ils
sont persuadés qu'il faut des nazifs et
l'Ukraine qu'il faut des militariser
l'Ukraine parce que nous sommes menacés
hors ce qu'ils disent dans les régions
c'est il faut pilonner l'Ukraine
Vladimir Poutine qui est depuis des
années nous fait cette démonstration de
puissance avec ces armes longues portées
pourquoi il n'en voit pas ses armes sur
les Ukrainiens pourquoi c'est nous qui
devons aller nous battre risquer nos
vies etc c'est ça le discours dans dans
la Russie profonde donc il s'interroge
tout le monde continue de soutenir
l'opération simplement ils disent il
faut l'amener à bien mais sans nous
parce que Vladimir Poutine il en a les
moyens il ils en sont toujours persuadés
comme ça
donc exactement ça il a pas les moyens
de de répliquer ou au contraire ce qui
va parvenir justement à répliquer
veillant Poutine là il y a ces
bombardements est-ce que derrière il va
y avoir une alliance justement avec le
cash and Co plus effectivement la
mobilisation c'est ça a priori la
riposte et encore une fois et là là nous
sommes à nouveau d'accord on ne sait pas
du tout ce qu'il va faire c'est on est
dans lui-même ne sait pas ce qu'il va
faire à mon avis il improvise on l'avait
dit l'autre jour sur ce plateau il
improvise il s'arroche des moyens et il
fait ce qu'il peut avec en fait général
brissait sur la menace nucléaire d'après
le Time Poutine prépare un test
nucléaire pour envoyer un signal
l'Occident j'ai lu d'ailleurs qu'on
parlait de l'arme de l'Apocalypse
Poséidon une arme nucléaire sous-marine
de longue portée pour frapper des villes
côtières qui seraient sur le point
d'être testé qu'en pensez-vous c'est une
information qui peut être prise avec
sérieux
je ne pense pas alors il y a deux choses
il y a d'abord l'utilisation d'une arme
nucléaire en Ukraine ou ailleurs dont on
parle régulièrement après que je
l'inscris et aussi
qu'il aurait fallu faire des frappes
préventives nucléaires donc
cet argument est brandi surtout du côté
ukrainien enfin été brandie du côté
ukrainien les Russes en parlent mais les
Russes ont une doctrine nucléaire assez
robuste et qui date de longtemps et leur
doctrine nucléaire ne prévoit pas
d'utilisation d'armement tactique pour
ce genre de conflit ça c'est une chose
ensuite on parle de cette torpille
nucléaire Poséidon c'est un missile à ce
qu'on appelle un changement de milieu
c'est-à-dire tiré par un sous-marin et
qui ensuite va se promener dans
l'atmosphère pendant des milliers de
kilomètres pour frapper une cible il
faut quand même savoir que la France n'a
pas encore ce genre de missile mais les
États-Unis et la Grande-Bretagne ont des
missiles de croisière parfaitement
capables d'être peut-être nucléaire donc
il y a rien de nouveau sur le plan des
armements si ce n'est des portées un
petit peu différentes et faites qu'on en
parle et le sous-marin qui est capable
de tirer ce genre de missile afin de
missiles de croisière nucléaire tiré
depuis un sous-marin ce sous-marin n'est
pas amené à se trouver dans un dans les
parages de l'Ukraine ni emmerdoise ni
même en Méditerranée
vous êtes d'accord est-ce que l'année en
général brissait en tout cas on l'a lu
beaucoup dans la presse qu'est-ce qu'on
dit du côté ukrainien que quand même ce
risque d'utilisation de ce type de
missile nucléaire est possible
moi je pense que chaque fois il faut
chercher les moyens de plus simple à
réagir et par exemple il faut pas
exclure peut-être la possibilité de
faire ceux qui ont dit une bombe sale
par exemple c'est quelque chose c'est
que ne pas si difficile à préparer c'est
à dire que je pense que Poutine quand
même il avance pas à pas il utilise
d'abord les méthodes plus simples et qui
est plus tard il va utiliser les
méthodes plus tard donc c'est possible
utiliser de faire les missiles dans
l'escalade disons ah oui dans le délicat
de l'escalade et il faut pas exclure de
rien c'est-à-dire quand maintenant on
fait on fait vraiment de prévisions on a
vu le c'est que ce qui a dit l'autre en
vitesse sur cette plateau qui est sur
qui on se trompe on n'a pas pensé qu'il
va attaquer donc moi je pense
personnellement et ce qui me semble
fonte le militaire ukrainien et
l'analyse absolument tout tout le
scénario et voilà pourquoi par exemple
on donne des yacht en cas où quelque
chose arrive tout tout le scénario sont
prévus et on se prépare et on exclut
rien
alors il y a aussi ce scénario pour du
coup d'État contre Poutine j'ai vu des
bellicistes qui tendraient par exemple
de mettre en avant un projet peut-être
plus efficace que celui de Vladimir
Poutine ou encore des réalistes c'est
l'autre scénario qui reconnaissent que
le seul moyen pour la Russie de
retrouver son statut de puissance ça
serait de se débarrasser de Poutine
est-ce que effectivement ce sont aussi
des scénarios possibles si vous voulez
qu'on a ces conversations de
l'utilisation de l'arme nucléaire ou du
coup d'État contre Poutine on vire un
peu si je peux me permettre enfin ces
personnes mais au café du commerce et
c'est ce qu'on fait tous parce qu'on en
est réduit à ça parce que on n'a pas ces
informations qui nous permettent
d'apporter ces fissures dans le système
quand même réduit on a eu des
oppositions j'ai eu un proche de Poutine
de certaines sources séjour-ci qui
continuent de me dire que le camp
sécuritaire disons les cidre qui fait
toujours bloc derrière Vladimir Poutine
qui mais je n'ai pas les moyens de
vérifier ces informations vous voyez
donc en fait on entend tout et son
contraire y compris de gens qui disent
avoir des sources dans la dans
l'appareil du Kremlin donc en fait on ne
sait pas en tout cas la seule chose que
moi je peux dire avec une certaine dose
d'assurance de ce que je comprends et de
ce que je connais de la société russe
c'est que je doute très fort de la
capacité des Russes à renverser poutine
au niveau de la révolution au niveau de
la rue etc s'il y avait un espoir pour
que tout qui s'arrête en tout cas pour
ceux qui disent que voilà si Vladimir
Poutine reste au pouvoir cette guerre va
continuer ce serait qu'il y ait un coup
d'État de l'intérieur mais de là à dire
est-ce que aujourd'hui oui il y a un
mécontentement du camp de la guerre qui
appelle Vladimir Poutine a frappé plus
fort il y a un mécontentement sans doute
des oligarques et et du camp civil des
fonctionnaires qui qui sont très
inquiets pour leur avenir mais de là à
dire est-ce qu'il y a une mutinerie
est-ce que est-ce qu'il se passe quelque
chose sous les ordres du Kremlin en
réalité on n'en sait rien on n'a aucun
élément pour pouvoir
Poutine pour reprendre le titre de
l'émission encore une fois c'est
complètement imprévisible c'est ça le
problème il s'est vraiment complètement
mis dans une situation impossible et là
il patauge il est il est comme quelqu'un
qui est en train de se sortir d'un de
sable mouvants quel geste va-t-il faire
pour pour s'en sortir on n'en sait rien
c'est il le sait-il lui-même et encore
une fois comme comme dit ma voisine de
gauche
il y a tout
je connais son nom
j'hésitais l'appeler par son prénom par
son nom de famille
est-ce qu'on
que va-t-il que va-t-il se passer on
n'en sait rien on n'a pas les moyens on
a pas les renseignements on n'a pas on
est reparti comme ceux à la guerre
froide ou les criminologue essayer de
deviner ce qui se passait en regardant
si quelqu'un sort son mouchoir en
regardant la parade du du 1er mai ou du
du 7 novembre on est on est reparti
comme des criminologue en train
d'essayer de deviner on joue aux
devinettes maintenant une chose
effectivement là où je suis également
tout à fait d'accord c'est que
tous les opposants russes qui comptent
aujourd'hui disent nous ne sommes pas
capables de faire un coup d'état et de
faire un soulèvement général parce que
il y a des beaucoup de raisons à cela
malheureusement la première étant que il
n'y a pas de position organisée et les
opposants qui existent sont très divisés
généralement conclure jusqu'où ira-t-il
Poutine
extrêmement difficile à dire pour le
moment je pense que Poutine attend
l'hiver pour une stabilisation du front
et que la stabilisation du front il va
se pouvoir être dans une position
défensive enfin mettre ses troupes dans
une position défensive assez solide et
avec des possibilités de frappe sur les
nœuds de communication à l'intérieur de
l'Ukraine parce que moi ce qui m'a
toujours étonné depuis le début c'est
que il y a pas eu de frappe sur les
systèmes d'approvisionnement électrique
il y a pas de frappe sur les systèmes
d'approvisionnement en eau il n'y a pas
de frappe sur Internet tout ça ça a été
laissé en état on nous dit on dit si si
il y a eu des frappes sur
l'approvisionnement en eau générale
minimalisme minimalisme et des deux
côtés il y a eu des frappes des deux
côtés à ce niveau là et il y a pas eu de
gros travail de guerre électronique de
rupture des communications et autres
donc tout ça ça m'étonne c'est une
volonté de ne pas se battre dans les
villes de ne pas recommencer à l'être un
souffle à Mario Paul il y a pas eu de
volonté des Russes de se battre dans les
villes oui mais lorsqu'on regarde je
sais pas si il faut je sais pas si vous
avez vu une photo générale aérienne de
Mario Paul il y a plus rien c'est comme
Berlin en 1945
il y a pas que Mario Paul qui a été rasé
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
général Jean Vincent Bruxelles merci
Elena Elena Volochine merci Oxana Oxana
microfanova d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir Merci à VOUS Oleg cops merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi et rester avec
nous sur France 24